[Music]
what if you could alter your perception
of time and space experience what it
feels like to be someone or something
else
a tree a lizard or
even a laugh
what if you could re-wire your mind and
take in the world anew like children do
what if psychedelics the compounds you
may know as magic mushrooms mescaline
acid ayahuasca and mdma among others
what if they were to change ages to help
you do all of this
here's the question would you be
interested in taking that trip
even if that trip might be terrifying
revealing things you just never wanted
to see
well
wall street is already betting on it
fueled by an explosion of ground
breaking psychedelic research that is
revolutionizing therapeutic approaches
to depression ptsd substance abuse
anxiety and end-of-life care
the hope
is that soon we can better understand
how psychedelics work not only to treat
depression but also possibly to enhance
the lives of the well unlocking
creativity boosting productivity and
catalyzing personal growth now
modern science may actually just be
catching up with what ancient peoples
already knew because for millennia
these substances have been used as
sacraments medicines and tools to shift
consciousness and expand the mind
the term psychedelic it it comes from
the greek words psyche meaning mind and
delos meaning manifest it was coined all
the way back in the 1950s by
english-born psychiatrist humphrey
osmond he's the one who introduced
novelist aldous huxley author of brave
new world in the doors of perception he
introduced him to mescaline and in a
letter exchange with huxley osman wrote
to fathom hell or sore angelic just take
a pinch
of psychedelic
now some of the world's most
accomplished scientists and creatives
francis crick carl sagan paul mccartney
steve jobs casey musgraves
they reportedly all took a pinch or two
of these mind altering compounds
ken casey
the author of one flew over the koopku's
nest said about the power of lsd
we discovered a new way to think and it
had to do with piecing together new
thoughts in your mind what is it that
scares people so deeply
perhaps they're afraid there's more to
reality than they have confronted well
maybe
but at the very least more to our
perceptions of reality than our usual
brain chemistry allows us to experience
and what's undeniable psychedelics can
modify that usual brain chemistry to
provide for
new paradigms of perception new
modes of experience that can be humbling
and electrifying and yes
sometimes frightening
so in tonight's program we are going to
explore why these compounds have
captivated humans for so long and take a
look at the latest scientific theories
regarding how they actually work in the
brain what are their benefits and the
pitfalls what is the impact of
psychedelics unconsciousness our
sense of connection and our capacity for
creativity
our conversation seeks to
educate and entertain and
just maybe
bring you a little dose of what might be
on the other side of huxley's famous
doors
of perception
[Music]
our first guest is rick doblin who is
the founder and executive director of
the multidisciplinary association for
psychedelic studies also known as maps a
pioneering activist and researcher he
has dedicated his life to legalizing
psychedelics and recently spearheaded
the world's first ever phase 3 clinical
trial investigating psychedelics which
produced extremely promising results for
ptsd patients using mdma assisted
therapy he joins us from his home in
belmont massachusetts welcome rick our
next guest is reggie watts who is an
internationally renowned musician
comedian actor and artist who currently
stars as the bandleader on cbs's the
late late show with james corden
throughout his life he has immersed
himself in psychedelic experiences that
have shaped his creative expression and
allowed him to explore consciousness
personal growth and the inner workings
of his delightfully weird subversive
mind he joins us from los angeles
welcome reggie
and finally we have gould dolan who is
an associate professor of neuroscience
at the johns hopkins university school
of medicine her laboratory's work
focuses on how plasticity and
neuromodulation governs social behavior
and recently her team made the
groundbreaking discovery that mdma can
reopen a novel critical period of brain
plasticity in mice which can potentially
be harnessed for a therapeutic benefit
in humans she joins us from oakland
california welcome ghoul
and welcome to you all thank you so much
for being here
we
are in the early stages of what future
generations may one day describe as a
kind of
psychedelic renaissance right a
resurgence of research and the use of
psychedelics as medicinal therapeutic
consciousness expanding chemicals
but as many people know these
psychedelic compounds they're they're
they're far from new right i mean
there's historical evidence that
suggests that for millennia indigenous
cultures from around the world west
africa to the americas they've used
naturally occurring psychedelics for
various forms of healing ritual practice
perhaps as a means some have said to
connect with imagined realms beyond me
every day in fact i have not checked on
this but i've heard maybe you guys know
that there's evidence that nearly every
culture on earth has utilized these mind
altering compounds so so reggie if i can
start with you
what do you think drives this timeless
cross-cultural use of psychedelics
um
i i think of it i think a lot of it has
to do with just human nature being
curious explorers
um i think there's something about
psychedelics that puts you uh they put
you in a state that allow you to feel
connected beyond your normal
input apparati so so there's this so
there's this kind of cruise
a cruise element to it meaning that a
drug puts you in a state that you can
experience something as opposed to
necessarily maybe meditation or
something where there's a practice to
arrive at that state this kind of
forces you into a state
or opens the gateway however you want to
look at it and i think that that is
exciting because it feels as though we
can
we're gaining knowledge that is beyond
what we're perceiving uh all the time or
something that matches our idea of what
a dream is or a waking dream or
something like that but it's an
interconnected curiosity
discovery
uh experience ritual ghoul what do you
think what's the what drives this
timeless fascination with psychedelics
yeah i i mean i guess i would say that
in some sense we are
entering altered states a lot um in our
normal lives when we go to sleep we have
an altered state when we fall in love we
have an altered state and as reggie was
suggesting i i think that the
psychedelics allow us to
jump into that realm faster and more
reliably and that's interesting and and
following that sense of curiosity um to
understand what is beyond our normal
everyday access
um i think um drives humans to do it but
i actually think that animals um there's
some evidence that animals also use
psychedelics and so it might not be a
human human-only characteristic
to be curious and playful and
try and understand beyond what we
normally have access to and you've
actually done experiments with animals
that you have provided them with
psychedelics which are going to talk
about a little bit later on but rick
what's your view
is it similar to what we heard from
reggie and ghoul is there another
motivation that drives cultures to use
these substances i think it's similar to
what they both said but i would add the
added dimension of the confrontation
with death and the meaning of life
and that what we see is that these
psychedelics have been used
throughout history for spiritual
purposes
and when we talk about indigenous
cultures that sort of makes it seem like
it's the other
but really it's the heart of the western
culture the elusivian mysteries
in greece you know the two thousand year
old mystery ceremonies that had an
element of
a psychedelic potion called kikion and
it was under pain of death to
keep quiet what happened but it was
about this confrontation with
death and what what does it mean to move
beyond our sense of our self as a
limited person from birth to death and
be part of this much bigger picture so i
think it's been essential as part of
meaning making finding our place in the
universe and when we talk about this
psychedelic renaissance that we're in
now i think a clearer way to think about
it is that it was around 392 when the
catholic church wiped out
the elusivian mysteries and this
experience of direct revelation through
psychedelics and ever since then there's
been the persecution of psychedelics
throughout history uh you know the
burning of the witches who used uh
various plant medicines the
evidence that early christians actually
used psychedelics
that there is this
power structure that has created
hierarchies that has sort of been
against the direct religious experience
and wanted to be the mediators and so
what we're talking about is
a time when humanity is in a massive
crisis we're in a self-destructive
spiral what we're doing to ourselves to
the animals to the environment
this more deeper spiritual sense of how
we're connected to everything is going
to be part of the
motivation to to write our course
as individuals and collective and that
psychedelics have always been a part of
that
and it's this combination of
spirituality and healing and also i
would add celebration and community
building now we've seen that rhythm here
in america right i mean the height the
recent height of psychedelic
research and use was in the 50s and 60s
i mean all of us
can think back or at least we know of
timothy leary rom das woodstock acid
test i mean the whole
movement at that time
which ultimately was quashed in a manner
reflective of the examples that you gave
before and look when i was growing up
and i grew up in the 60s
i don't know about you all but i was
told i mean my mother told me you do any
of these psychedelic drugs and your mind
will fry
you will have flashbacks for the rest of
your life that will destroy any
possibility of being normal so that was
inculcated in me as a young kid i mean
reggie did you hear i mean anything like
that growing up or was it more of a
benign view or maybe no view at all
regarding psychedelics
um
yeah i mean i kind of loosely knew about
it as a kid because i grew up in montana
in the 80s and 70s and the 80s and so
you kind of heard some you know
murmurings and rumors about psychedelics
and maybe in school there would be like
an anti-drug thing about like pcp for
some reason that was a big one that they
really didn't want you to do but we
couldn't get it in montana so i don't
know why they were showing us those
videos but uh you know there there was a
an awareness of of a substance that you
can take that makes you go
you know and that was my knowledge um so
there wasn't really a lot of danger
other than if you do this you'll want
you'll think you can fly
uh or something like that you know like
and it was like obviously misinformation
but of course like when we were 16 or 15
or i was 16 i experienced lsd for the
first time and of course all of that
changed and then so much came into
perspective but um
yeah i didn't really grow up with
necessarily like this is really bad it's
more like uh stay away from it but it's
just kind of like a light warning sure
yeah google how about you growing up was
there any talk of these substances i
mean i grew up in texas and you know at
the same time you know 70s and 80s and
really the the war on drugs and this is
your brain on drugs for some reason in
my mind that was more about you know
cocaine and heroin for the big scary
ones um pcp also we heard lots of
stories of people like murdering
families and not remembering it the next
day kind of scare stories but
yeah lsd and magic mushrooms those were
like i sort of vaguely heard about them
but it wasn't like the same scariness i
think some of that had had
um
faded away by the time of my childhood
so yeah now rick you've you've put
heroic effort into trying to turn the
tide on psychedelics i mean what's
happened in roughly the last decade and
and do you feel that the tide at least
in america is finally turning to more
positive
light on psychedelics
yeah i do feel that the tide has turned
it's not the case that it couldn't turn
back again but i think we have an
excellent opportunity
to bring psychedelics into the
mainstream and
you know again it's not just recovering
from half a century ago the backlash
against the 60s but it's really
recovering against you know sixteen
hundred years ago the backlash against
psychedelics in general from western
culture
i think that we've learned a lot from
the 60s
and we've integrated a lot as a culture
we've really
re-oriented our approach towards death
you know now in the 60s with the
psychedelics where this death rebirth
this uh psychological process that goes
on people didn't talk about physical
death at the time if you had cancer you
didn't even talk about it back then in
the 60s if you were
a meditator that was weird and then here
we got the beatles bringing these guys
in robes from india the maharishi match
yogi for transcendental meditation
that was really weird and suspicious and
there was concerns about yoga if you
practiced yoga you would lose your
christianity and become like a hindu or
a buddhist or something like that i was
of course told that if you took lsd six
or seven times that you were then
certifiably insane
and then right that would be your
diagnosis for the rest of your life
what's been accomplished in the last 10
years the research has progressed both
with mdma and with psilocybin into
substantial evidence
of
efficacy and safety
so
it is pretty amazing that we are now
talking about these substances as as
legitimate medicines and i understand it
rick your organization is currently in
phase three clinical trials of mdma
assisted psychotherapy for
patients with ptsd and for those who
don't know that's the final stage of
research before fda approval is granted
which
i hear could happen rick
in the next couple of years for mdma
we're the leading edge we're the only
group that has so far started phase
three we've completed one phase three
study
and just to emphasize how
important this transition is the journal
science puts out a list at the end of
each year about the top 10 scientific
discoveries and scientific breakthroughs
of the last year and there's one winner
and nine runner-ups
and the winner was protein folding as
figured out through artificial
intelligence but one of the other ones
was mdma research by maps for mdma
assisted therapy for ptsd as one of the
top 10 scientific breakthroughs of the
year all over the world so i think
what's really happened is we finally
have the data
about safety and efficacy in
fda and other regulatory agencies
approved studies
and we've gotten publications in the
major scientific journals so that it's
pretty much clear to
everybody who's uh unbiased and paying
attention that there are contexts where
the benefits can outweigh the risks and
where people who have previously been
unable to get relief from the currently
available treatments are able to make
progress with psychedelic assisted
therapy and that's fantastic now so so
therapeutics may as you say be the mode
by which psychedelics come back into the
mainstream use but um their role
in revealing the
capacities of this glopy grey thing
inside of our head to have experiences
well beyond the everyday is another
aspect that i find
deeply fascinating i have to also say
deeply frightening i'd love to hear your
experiences but i'll quickly share one
of mine years ago i was asked to give a
talk to the queen of holland and i went
and gave this talk in amsterdam and
afterwards i have to say my wife and i
decided to cut loose a little bit and we
went and we ingested some of these
foreign substances and i took too little
didn't affect me my wife had an
interesting time so the next night when
we went back to do it again at this
coffee house
the list of options were all coded by
imagery clouds and balloons and colors
normal sense ordinary sense of time or
any sense of space somehow we got back
to the hotel room and i remember
just feeling so unmoored that i asked my
wife to tie me to the bed post for no
you know untoward purpose i was just
afraid what i was gonna do you know so i
just wanted to be anchored to something
heavy that would keep me literally
grounded so in the end i found it a
valuable experience because it made it
so clear to me that there are modes of
consciousness that are very different
from the everyday it sort of resonated
with something i read much later on from
william james that he he said that our
everyday lives and our everyday
experiences or but one special type of
consciousness
parted as he said by the flimsiest
screen from forms of consciousness
entirely different so
definitely valuable but definitely also
terrifying reggie you mentioned that you
had your first lsd experience with the
15 or 16. i mean what was that like um
it was super chill i didn't really care
about it no just kidding um i uh it was
it was uh
it was cool i mean i you know i was
obviously like a little nervous about
taking
a you know a tab of paper yeah this
little square of paper is going to do
something you know it didn't really make
sense it was very mysterious
and um took it and i remember i was at a
friend's house we started in a friend's
house
and um
yeah i was like hanging out in
a room with a friend
and it started coming on and i just
remember
when it first started happening i was
like whoa whoa like you know because
when you haven't had that experience
before it's so
it's so amazing to have it revealed to
you you know like it just kind of fades
in and as it fades in
it's kind of disbelief but also like oh
i kind of thought that this is what it
would be like but of course i've never
felt anything like this at the same time
like a paradoxical realization and so
that that that got bigger then we went
out into a street we found a top of a
one of those things called the apple
drink it doesn't exist anymore i'll
remember the name of it anyways it had
like a clicky top yeah another one you
could put it on the top of the metal and
it would go in and out kind of thing
yeah yeah totally yeah so what one of my
friends found one on the street and they
were just like
click click and they would hide and then
click
and we were like
and so we went on this huge like hide
and seek and trying to capture the
clicker thing just trying to get it from
each other and then we decided to go
camping in the middle of the evening and
we got into cars and drove
uh it's montana
but we drove and we drove about maybe 15
miles out of town and just had to stop
and we pulled off to the side of the
road
very empty road and i remember going to
the side of the road my friends were
doing something off by the car i was on
the other side of the road i went into a
ditch i found a little bar crossbar that
was like the reflective orange stripes
on it that would be connected to the
horses so i grabbed just this bar i got
up out of the ditch stood in the middle
of the road and held it in the middle of
the road and thought it was
the most hilarious thing in the universe
i couldn't stop laughing i just stood in
the road holding this crossbar this
reflective
barrier just laughing my ass off and so
that was basically my trip what what it
what it what it exposed
was the silliness of the universe the
silliness and the absurdity of life and
consciousness it's all hilarious it's
funny it's very funny and very weird so
that was kind of my first trip no that's
a hugely important lesson
it's a great way to get to it rick how
about you do you remember your earliest
or first or memorable
psychedelic experience oh yeah i
definitely do but before we get there
i'd like to say what was those uh
machine guns what what was the drug that
you actually took
no i have no idea and i suspect that it
was extraordinarily mild because i
rarely drink
i don't smoke i don't take any foreign
substances so i think that my body was
so unused to this kind of a shift that
even the most modest of drugs would have
a radical impact so i don't know the
answer but i think it was very mild i
think it's the kind of thing that most
people wouldn't have that kind of
reaction on
yeah probably was it something that you
smoked or swallowed you smoked
okay actually i have to ask my wife i
don't know i think it was smoked i'm
going to ask her okay so i don't i don't
it's weird that i don't completely
remember
yeah i think it was it is
because it's something that
in the coffee houses it could have been
very strong hash maybe
yeah that they only have legal
permission to put out cannabinoids and
also
uh mushroom truffles
and they're very
careful about that so chances are it was
if it was smoked
you know i don't think it was dmt or
anything that doesn't match your
description because dmt is so fast and
then it's over within you know an hour
or less oh this was many hours yeah so
it sounds like it could be a super
strong marijuana or maybe something yeah
uh if it was smoked um
it's it's surprising it probably
wouldn't be anything else but but the
point
most people in the audience right now
they're like rolling their eyes you know
brian green smokes a little weed and
goes into this crazy place but uh but so
so thank you for that i really good for
you though yeah yeah exactly yeah you're
efficient but but what it points out is
that the when we talk about psychedelics
and we talk about therapy it's really
therapy and the psychedelics make the
therapy more effective
and it's not about just the substance
it's the context it's your attitude and
so the parts that you're saying are
frightening there's a losing control
there's a letting the ego control the
ego is dissolved there's uh losing
control losing a sense of who you are
one of my favorite albums from the 60s
is by david crosby from crosby stills
nation young and and many other groups
and it's a solo album but he's got
everybody from all the different groups
and the title of the album is if i could
only remember my name
and that i think is a really good
description of if you've taken a
significant amount of psychedelics
there's a period of time where you can't
remember your name you're disconnected
from
your sense of self we could get into
google could explain about the default
mode network or just other neuroscience
aspects of it but
what happened to me on my very first
experience
was
with it was with lsd and it was when i
was 17 years old
i was just in college
and what had convinced me to try it
because i really did believe that it
would
if you took it six or seven times you
know that you would be certifiably
insane that it was gonna damage your
chromosomes and you would have deformed
babies what made me first question that
was a book that i read in my senior year
of high school and i loved this book
and a friend of mine loaned it to me and
when i gave it back to him he said that
the author had written part of that book
under the influence of lsd
and i said that's impossible nothing
good comes from lsd it's just a
hallucination it's it's all unreal and
he convinced me to check into it and it
turned out he was right it was one flew
over the cuckoo's nest by ken kesey
and part of that had been written under
the influence of lsd so that the whole
edifice of propaganda sort of fell apart
after i read that book and then my first
experience was difficult it was
frightening in similar ways but not
quite as extreme as the way that you
described it in that i was
losing myself a sense of who i was
it was frightening to let that go i was
much more in my head i wasn't very
emotionally fluid at all and there was
all these feelings that were coming up
that were difficult for me to process it
was
1971
at college
and i just had these intimations of
something
uh deeper and broader and connecting me
to something bigger and yet a lot of was
this struggle of
having the courage to let go and being
scared of it
of doing that but it was enough of
the good parts of the sense of a
different way to process
that made me think i should keep trying
it yeah it's amazing
ghoul is that
you know my experience the experiences
that we heard of what rick just
described
it all comes from
some atoms arranged into certain
molecular forms
that do something within the human body
to change our sense of self and our
sense of everyday experience i mean i
think we have an image of the lsd
molecule if we can bring it up
can can you know you look at that
molecule right it's got some nitrogen
some carbon some hydrogen
would you look at that molecule and say
that's going to have this kind of
profound effect on human experience
well i mean i have to say
when i was in college i um
i designed my own major it was you know
comparative perspectives on the mind and
it was you know partially philosophy
partially neuroscience partially
religion
partially art and um
you know i was sort of dabbling with
more focusing in philosophy and when i
saw this exact picture right next to the
serotonin molecule
i i was just blown away you know i
thought oh my god this is the thing
that's going to help us understand
all of those hard problems of
consciousness of you know all the
things that felt like they were too much
philosophy and would never be solved by
neuroscience and i really
you know radically switched directions
in that first class i took on drugs
brain and behavior because of this sort
of consciousness altering properties of
a compound that looks very similar to
serotonin and to me that was evidence
that you know a molecule like the all of
these complex big
emotions
cognitive changes
our sense of reality our sense of self
our sense of the eternal come down to
molecules and and i think that you know
if you surveyed neuroscientists you'd
find that a large proportion of them
sort of
got into neuroscience in in a similar
way yeah you know there's something else
to add brian let me let me said one
quick thing which is that the discovery
of serotonin actually was in part
because of lsd
and various scientists have written
about that because when lsd was being
explored in the late 40s early 50s
the question was how could something so
tiny in millionths of a gram
have such a profound
experience on consciousness and that led
to people theorizing that there must be
some similar kind of
neurotransmitters or something like that
in the brain
and that's really prompted the search
for things like serotonin i see and and
so so what does this serotonin-like
molecule this lsd molecule
what does it do inside the brain does it
latch on to specific places i mean do we
know its action at a chemical molecular
level
yeah so lsd is like many compounds what
we call a dirty drug it binds to
hundreds thousands of receptors
and
but we know from a lot of different
types of uh information that the binding
of the lsd molecule to the serotonin 2a
receptor which is one of 14 subtypes of
serotonin receptors when it binds to
that receptor
it gets into the binding pocket and then
it sort of gets trapped in its hole and
so instead of
triggering the normal biochemical
cascade that happens when serotonin
binds to that receptor
it triggers a different cascade
because it's sitting in there for so
long
we think that that's what makes the
effect of lsd binding to the serotonin
receptors so different from serotonin
binding to that i see so serotonin is
this chemical that's a neurotransmitter
that helps electrical signals go from
neuron to neuron you're saying lsd sort
of mimics it but in some sense you're
saying it binds even more strongly
to the receptor location than serotonin
itself
would it's not binding more strongly it
just
takes longer for it to come off i see
um and and and so i'd like to get into a
little later on
that knowledge giving us insight into
the actual effect itself but before that
i kind of want to backtrack a little bit
somewhat beyond the nuts and bolts of
the molecular impact of these chemicals
get to the the mind stuff that we've
already alluded to previously in our own
experiences um look many of us were
introduced to psychedelics and the
potential of these chemicals
by the book by aldous huxley back in the
50s the doors of perception
and he
vividly in that book describes his own
psychedelic experiences and i was
frankly going to
read an excerpt one of my favorite
excerpts but reggie i think you could do
much better job
embodying the english sure philosopher
aldous huxley do you mind reading that
passage
yes uh yes i hope i get the part
you're on now
reggie watts reading for the part of
dialogue
uh reader
to be shaken out of the ruts of ordinary
perception to be shown for a few
timeless hours the outer and inner world
not as they appear to an animal obsessed
with survival or to a human being
obsessed with words
and notions but as they are apprehended
directly and unconditionally by mind at
large
this is an experience of inestimable
value to everyone and especially to the
intellectual
you know the only problem is that i want
you to just read the rest of the book
and you'll just forgo the conversation
but um sure i'll start at chapter one
yeah please absolutely go right back to
the beginning but uh but but right when
you read that as wonderfully as you just
said what what do you think is that
an accurate assessment i mean is that
like literary flourish that comes from
an articulate writer is that is that
pretty um on the mark
well i think you know i i think that the
essence of of the psychedelic experience
uh the uncovering is really paradox or
what i call i like to call i'm sure a
lot of people call it the paradoxical
state and so from once you've
experienced the paradoxical state the
self-non-self uh the whatever you want
to call it apply all uh binaries and and
annihilate them but this is the type of
language that comes out of it because
wisdom things that spark ideas and so
forth are based off of a con like
contrasting elements that arrive at
paradoxical conclusions so the flowery
language that kind of dances around this
idea of negation
positivity and negation and both
simultaneously that's with that without
that sounding like crazy but but once
you find that intersection and that
happens in all states uh in anything
that you do
then this type of language if you have a
love of language and and languages code
essentially is what this reminds me of
uh it's it's it's meant to deprogram to
defrag the mind from its normal idea of
what it thinks
things are so defragging once more
there's another passage if you don't
mind oh yes
it's uh it's his huxley's description of
a chair that he perceives under the
influence of a psychedelic substance if
you can just uh take that one away
okay sure
this one's the easiest of of them all
that i've done the legs for example of
that chair how miraculous their
tubularity how supernatural their
polished smoothness
spent several minutes or was it several
centuries not merely gazing at those
bamboo legs but actually being them or
rather
being myself in them or to be still more
accurate for i was not involved in the
case nor in a certain sense were they
being my not self
in the not self
which was the chair
amazing i mean does that i mean rick
does that does that resonate that
description
um it it does a lot of these boundaries
are collapsed as reggie was saying is
that a van gogh chair by
it looks kind of like a van gogh
painting indeed it is indeed it is ben
yeah well
okay
but yeah that totally resonates and i
think that that's why these substances
have been used for thousands of years
that they give this
sense to people that we're not isolated
from the environment around us that
we're a part of it we're an intimate
part of it the world is an intimate part
of ourselves at this deeper level we're
connected and beyond that there may be
some connection to
sort of the timeless energies that you
can talk to us about in terms of uh
general relativity or
you know other aspects of modern physics
that nothing is um
you know energy is not uh destroyed it's
just uh
transformed and i think when people can
get that it changes their attitudes
towards death it changes their attitudes
towards life and they can live in a more
full way and and so i think that what
all this huxley was describing which was
with masculine
was um very much what a lot of other
people the one thing i would disagree
with where huxley talked about it he
talked about it as special value for
intellectuals
and in the work in the 60s there was a
lot of
work with lsd for alcoholics and heroin
addicts done
at johns hopkins and spring grove and
and stan groff who was my mentor and was
the world's leading lsd researcher and
developed holotrophic breath work a
non-drug way to
influence uh consciousness in similar
ways he just talked about how some of
these skid row bumps that were major
alcoholics still had these profound
spiritual experiences they didn't have
the words that huxley did to describe
them
but it's more of a feeling
it doesn't require this intellectual
sophistication and i think that was one
of the challenges you could say during
the 60s which was this
view by huxley and others that this
psychedelic should be reserved for
intellectuals and then you could say ken
kesey and
timothy leary and others felt that it
should be more democratized
right everyone should have access to it
yeah now many you know perception is one
thing and it's a it's a vital part of
the experience of course but but many
people have reported as you made
reference before to a sense of ego death
or ego dissolution they report a sense
of
oneness with the universe around them a
sort of deep connectedness that that
many have suggested reveals a deeper
level of reality than we have access to
in everyday life now look as a card
caring physicalist materialist
reductionist i'm i'm certainly open to
that idea but it seems more reasonable
to me and i would love for you all to
weigh in seems unreasonable to me that
these experiences are revealing
something
deep about our inner world about are the
workings of our brains the workings of
our minds but they're not revealing
something about the outer world i mean
google do you have a
perspective on that
i think this kind of gets at um a little
bit of a property that william james
talked about
the noetic property this ability to feel
like what you are
experiencing with psychedelics is the
really real and that it's been revealed
to you in this process
um i think for a mathematician you know
they might interpret the same um
psychedelic experience in terms of
asymptotics
i think the good friday experiment is a
good example of what if you put a if you
put a bunch of priests in a room and
give them psychedelics they're going to
see god if you
you know give a bunch of neuroscientists
psychedelics they're going to be like ah
it's the serotonin molecule of course
and aldous huxley actually also tried to
address this you know he proposed
mechanistically that the way that this
was happening was uh because
psychedelics sort of opened up some he
called it the reducing valve as a
neuroscientist i always imagined that to
be sort of a part of the part of the
brain called the thalamus that sort of
um
as information is coming into the brain
from the outside world um sort of
uh
filters that information and only a
subset of that information actually gets
up to the higher parts of the brain and
that's what i imagined the psychedelics
were doing widening that filter letting
in more information but actually there's
evidence now that that's not the case in
fact if anything the psychedelics what
they're doing is allowing brain
processing to be more influenced by
what we call a neuroscience the prior so
what you already
what conceptions what configurations
what
associations your brain was already
making have a greater influence on the
way that you interpret that information
so you say more influenced by the priors
i i intuitively would have thought the
reverse that we are these
bayesian probabilistic prediction-making
machines in order to
navigate the external world effectively
we constantly guess what's really
happening in the world and i would have
thought that psychedelics
minimized the
restricted view of the world that that
probabilistic framework provides
allowing us to have a wider range of
experience but you're saying that that's
completely wrong well i mean i think
it's it's
so what we're talking about now is
specifically about the hallucinations
which is not to me equivalent to the
psychedelic experience right so i want
to i just want to make a distinction you
know i think historically what we've
talked about is you know the classical
psychedelics some people even go further
and say the serotonin psychedelics and a
lot of that i think is just trying to
classify things to try and get a handle
on how they're working and i think um
you know people like alexander shulgin
you know defined it differently for
shulgin he um is a was a chemist and he
did a lot of work with mdma and other
psychedelic drugs for shulgin and many
others
psychedelic just means
something that produces an altered state
of consciousness whether or not that has
a hallucinogenic property
is not actually a requirement of it
being a psychedelic and there are
hallucinogenic
um
uh you know people have hallucinations
for a number of other reasons that have
nothing to do with psychedelics right
and there are different types of
hallucinations and so i don't want to
equate the two things
but our studies of you know
hallucinations themselves does seem to
suggest that this
opening up the filter idea isn't quite
right and that rather it's more of this
biasing and i don't want to speak too
abstractly but like if you're on a
psychedelic and you're looking at a
picture a static photograph of a
waterfall right
people who are on psychedelics will tend
to interpret that as moving water and so
that would be a good example of how
your prior knowledge of waterfalls
containing water that moves
influencing your ability to hallucinate
a waterfall from a static photograph but
that prior you're saying triumphs over
the other prior which is when we see
paintings on a wall
we usually predict that they're going to
be static so you're saying that those
two prizes are somehow
competing and it's the one that focuses
just on the water itself that that water
usually flows wins out in that case yeah
it just tends to be yeah so goul made
one point there which is if you give
psychedelics to a group of priests
they're gonna see god which is an
example i gather of the mantra that i've
i've read a lot about that set and
setting is is so vital to the experience
that one has on psychedelic one's
mindset in the physical setting so so if
you think back
is there say a frightening psychedelic
experience that you've had which you can
trace to
a set and setting that somehow wasn't
conducive to perhaps a more
bright enjoyable open
ended experience than the one you
actually had
yeah i think the word is safe
that's that's the when it comes to
psychedelics generally it's
the feeling of safety being safe to be
able to relax and
not go into the uh
you know death based uh
probabilistic projection models and so
which will cause a lot of
a large shadow of gloom to appear very
quickly but
not necessarily and not also not always
bad
i would say uh
i've been i've been uh
experimenting a lot with uh ketamine
and
while that is it's a different type of
psychotropic psychedelic it's like i
guess
people call it inward psychedelic uh
inwardly psychedelic um i've definitely
i was at a dance party
and a friend of mine wanted to try some
k
and i thought i usually never do this i
usually if i do it i do it at home i
have a prescription
i do it at home i lay on a bed i have
surround sound high-end speakers i uh
you know have water next to me i have
the temperature you know like there's
all of these factors so i can you know
go on this journey however in this
particular case a friend of mine had
never done it wanted to try it i thought
well it's it is a music festival maybe
that's a cool place who knows we did
apparently just a little bit too much
and she went out on the dance floor and
i before she went out i said this was at
the very beginning i was like you might
get a little
wobbly so you may
want to not go out there but she went
out anyways which is totally fine it's
great she was out there and then i
started to feel it i was doing like a a
press thing or something backstage real
quick i got up and was like i better
check
i went through the curtain
all these crazy people dancing uh
halloween vibes and she was she was like
hanging on
to
a couch that was a part of the wall like
a vinyl long old-school kind of 70s
style couch and so i got up next to her
and she grabbed on me and we both sat
down in this chair and our friend who
was not on k
uh was like yeah i'm gonna get out of
here and we're like why are you leaving
right now and so she took off and it was
just her and i and we got so
into a k-hole like we were definitely
k-hole adjacent or
one foot in a k-hole
it was pretty strong and i felt like i
couldn't get up if i got up i was going
to fall down i didn't really understand
the mechanics of
physics at that at that point i don't
know how it would get into my body to
pilot it so
we just sat there and it felt like there
was this bubble around us and people
would come up and say hey man nice show
i did a show that night hey man nice
show and then one guy was trying to sell
me on a festival that he was putting
together and
managed or he said he managed timothy
leary it's obviously not true but he had
my ear for a very long time i had to
figure out ways to mechanically push or
or tell people hey i'm i'm tripping
right now so can you please give me some
space but i was trying everything before
that because i thought that that was bad
to say uh however
that happened for a very very long time
it was like withstanding a storm you
know like hoping that the
hatch is held
but at the same time an amazing
experience because we had to figure out
how to get out of it uh we had to find a
moment where i i felt confident enough
to stand up and she felt confident
enough that i felt confident enough to
stand up and just make it
15 feet through a curtain so that was
that was that was probably the most
craziest trip darkest trip what did you
take away from that i mean did it
influence you that you didn't want to do
it again later on or you just put it
into the list of things of experiences
in a psychedelic state okay
no i i'm not that kind of person i have
a lot of friends who are like i had this
really bad
mushroom trip i'll never do mushrooms
again it's like dude i smoked too much
pot once and i can't have it and i'm
always like there is that part of me
inside it's like well you just didn't
try hard enough or you know there's like
this kind of like this [ __ ]
extreme guy that's like you know chewing
gum leaning up against a locker i don't
know who that guy is but um
but i would say
generally when that happens i compare it
to my other experiences and i think
about the context of it because that has
a huge effect on it usually i won't give
up if i've yielded really good results
uh in the past and with ketamine
definitely i've yielded amazing results
in the past from my childhood we used to
also do dextromethorphan as well so it
has a similar uh dissociative nature to
it and i find that an interesting place
so that experience definitely showed me
not the the wrong situation to be in on
it but it doesn't dissuade me from
experiencing it again so rick a number
of researchers have been trying to
go from the molecular understanding of
these chemicals to
the effects that they have on us can you
just give a sense of
of what the default mode network is what
this entropic brain theory is and how
this might give us insight into
this ego dissolutionist loss of sense of
self under the influence of psychedelics
yeah well um there's a structure of the
brain the default mode network that's
more or less identified with our sense
of self
and what the psychedelics tend to do
more the classic psychedelics
is that they weaken activity in the
default mode network so you're not
filtering information in the same way
and then you're getting
uh much more
unfiltered information that's raw that's
more direct
that goes beyond a lot of these
distinctions that we make between us and
the external world
and that's where you see this you know
sense of how you're blending with other
things
i would say it's ego death is the wrong
word ego dissolution which you used it
was a good eye good way to to talk about
it because there's still a an observing
self
in some way or that's the sort of
mystery about it is that google talked
about hallucinations and the priors
in a sense and it'll come to answer your
question as well so that it's different
from normal hallucinations what we think
is that under psychedelics it doesn't
quite match what we think of as a
hallucinate hallucination where you
think something's there that's not
really there this is kind of this
internal world projected on the outside
world and that's where we get to the
priors and so just to give you an
example of one time where i was working
with someone who had ptsd from sexual
assault and this was with mdma and
during the experience there was this
um discussion that she started
re-experiencing this original trauma and
then part of the time she was seeing
this the rapist's face
and body superimposed on my body and
other times she was seeing me shining
through and other times so it was a
question of could she trust was she but
it was that she was seeing through her
priors
and it was overlaid on the universe but
and on me but something underneath it
was this healing process where when she
was able to release the fears and the
anxieties and that she had to suppress
when the incident was happening because
she was focusing on survival that she
could then process it in a different way
and then
it sort of moved from just uh
being this blend of me and the rapist to
just being me
and for her to have made a peace with it
so a lot of times the hallucinations you
could say are making your priors visible
and you can see how then you overlay the
world with this and that you can you
know people that are depressed overlay
the world what this is going to be a
this is going to turn out badly or i
can't trust this or that and that's how
people see the world and then you can
see through that through this
therapeutic process
and then when you come back to normal
consciousness you've rewired your brain
for some of these memories and it's not
the they're not processed in the same
way they don't trigger the same kind of
emotional
notes in your memories they're routed
differently in your brain so you know
this idea of this stability of how you
see things is shaken up i just want to
say one last thing too about you talked
about it does it really reveal more of
what's in your mind than what's in your
universe what's outside in the world and
i would say that
you know we understand that through the
quantum level that we're all connected
it's energy there's very little matter
you know mostly space between different
things we're connected in these energy
waves but we don't see the world that
way but that is about the world we tend
to see things as solid objects distinct
from others but it's a valid part of the
world and it's another way of looking at
the world so i think psychedelics give
us the chance to
not just understand about
the inner workings of our brain but can
indeed give us
a better insights into how the world
itself is organized yeah the only thing
i would say on on that i mean i'm open
to the idea but one thing i would say is
in quantum mechanics this strange
description of the external world in
terms of probability waves and quantum
entanglement and things of that sort it
yields testable predictions about the
external world that are objectively
available to any experimenter and they
all get the same answer and that's what
gives us confidence that we're truly
talking about something
that is characteristic of the external
reality whereas the experiences that
we're talking about
they are highly subjective highly
individualized and that is what at least
leads me to the possibility that it's
really revealing what's happening in
here much more than telling us something
about out there i would say one thing
and this is just my
uh
outsider uh amateur observationalist uh
uh part-time psychonaut warrior person i
i would say that
for instance improvising music which is
something that i love to do or if i'm on
stage and i'm improvising
you enter into a state that is kind of
not really in time it's perceived
by myself or other people playing along
and so forth as
as extra time there's a there's a buffer
that gets created so you feel like
you're slightly in the future i don't i
don't i don't think there's any way to
prove that or test that who knows but it
feels as though you have options ahead
of you and what is being experienced by
those
around you outwardly perceiving what's
going on is in the past and to a certain
degree most things are but uh in music
or improvisation that's where you get
this kind of um
this psychic effect where someone knows
that this is the next chord change
someone knows that this is when a drum
fill is going to happen you've almost
previewed previewed it in your mind and
when it happens you're like yeah that
was what was supposed to happen um and i
think this thing that i say like the
paradoxical state it's like the observer
and the experiencer like i kind of view
these two things you know in metaphysics
or where we talk about higher self lower
self you know there's all kinds of names
for it but there is conscious the nature
of consciousness is comp a comparison
something aware that the of itself
against something else so uh the paradox
which i which i love is when when i get
into these states and why i call it that
is because there it is everything and
nothing nothing and everything and in
that that moment it doesn't really
matter how you interpret or what you
interpret because time is the thing that
lays down the idea of what you're trying
to bring into the material world quote
unquote the experience itself is in is
undescribable because it's it is a
needle on the on the record you know
it's like whatever is before the the
needle and whatever whatever is behind
the needle it doesn't matter you can't
experience it you can only experience
what the needle is experiencing in that
moment and then remove the needle and
it's suddenly gone so i guess what i'm
trying to say is i feel like when i take
psychedelics or psychotropics it's it's
allowing me to just freely flow as a
consciousness and in doing so it reminds
me of holographic holographic principles
where things can happen at a distance in
different location locations and so
forth i wouldn't be surprised if
everything is just a holographic
cascading consciousness awareness of
itself infinitely looking at itself and
so
being binary individuals uh we want to
know there's a start or a beginning or
an end or there's a linear path and so
forth which is totally valid however it
is quite possible that it is neither in
both and that's just not fun to think
about so so are psychedelics of it don't
mind me asking are they a vital part of
what allows you to do what you do on
stage and in performance are they
part of the bedrock that allows you to
be so incredibly creative and incredibly
free in your associations when you're in
an improvisational context
i i'd say that they're helpful in that
um i've i've definitely had moments on
psychedelics and psychotropics uh that
are
you know where i'm experiencing extra
time like what i call extra time you
know uh where
i feel like i see something about to
occur or i feel see something that's
about to occur and it just it just
occurs it happens or i turn just as
someone's coming around the corner and
and something's arriving but i'd say uh
it to put to put yourself in that space
and to put yourself in that mode
opens you up to uh the lack of loss of
control allowing yourself to relinquish
control and that's why when you say like
uh earlier you're like i know you don't
like to be prepared it's like i don't
like to be prepared i don't want any
notes i don't want to know what anything
is when i go before i go into an
interview before anything the least
amount of information possible is is
much better for me i'd rather learn in
that instance in that moment in real
time that's a much more interesting yeah
no it's a powerful way of being able to
uh engage with these sorts of uh public
discussions or public performances cool
your work we we heard rick describe some
of the research that's being done on the
default mode network and the entropic
brain approach you have a different
approach i understand where you think
about psychedelics and their
relationship to neuroplasticity
and critical periods i guess this goes
all the way back to uh conrad lawrence
and up to the experiments on where
you've had mice that have taken
psychedelics can you just take us
through a little bit of what you have
been doing and your view of how it is
that psychedelics do what they do inside
the human brain you know you said it and
i just want to make it clear that you
know this is a different theory than the
um
sort of
default mode network and so basically
the idea is is that
um you know as the brain matures
we go through these periods of time
where um we're extremely sensitive to
stimuli in the environment and the brain
is very malleable and sensitive and
absorbs that information and changes
memories and encodes memories in a very
sensitive way during those phases that
we call critical periods and the first
one that was described was conrad lorenz
describing imprinting behavior in snow
geese so this is the behavior where
if a snow geese is a hatchling and you
know sees a flying object that is not
its mother within the first 24 hours
then it'll form a lifelong attachment to
that flying object whether it be an
airplane or maybe it's just conrad
lorenz himself and they'll form that
attachment and it'll be like their
attachment to their mother normally
would be for the rest of their lives but
if you wait 48 hours after hatching and
expose them to that flying object or
conrad lorenz then they don't form that
long-lasting attachment and that concept
is called a critical period and there
are lots of critical periods so there's
critical periods for language there's
critical periods for
motor learning learning how to ride a
bike there's critical periods for vision
for organizing how we process sensory
information depth perception visually
you know music probably there's a a
critical period and so neuroscientists
pretty much for the last almost hundred
years since conrad lorenz described
critical periods have been looking for
ways to reopen critical periods and this
is because we've recognized that you
know we've got all these therapies out
there
that we keep you know coming up with
good ideas on how to tr treat diseases
of the brain
and they just keep failing in clinical
trials and we suspect that they might be
failing because by the time we correct
whatever is broken
um the critical period the relevant
critical period is already closed and so
if we had a way of reopening critical
periods then we might be able to
restore that ability of the brain to to
take the information under the corrected
circumstances right so the best example
of you know what that might look like is
you know in in blindness for example
people who are born with cataracts
bilaterally if you don't remove those
cataracts before the closure of the
visual critical period even when you do
remove them they'll just be blind
forever right so the idea is is that if
you could
have some way of reopening that visual
critical period that um
that um removing the cataracts later on
in life would be helpful and so
um this has just been a quest of
neuroscience for you know decades
and we haven't really succeeded all of
the things that we've tried um just
haven't really worked that well
and so it was really exciting to us
my lab discovered a new critical period
a critical period for social reward
learning so we think this cr and we
discovered this in mice and we think
that social reward learning critical
period
is is relevant to how we
learn the social rules in our society
how we learn that it's rude to you know
not cross your legs and whatever or that
it's rude to interrupt an elder you know
these kinds of social rules we learn
when we're young and we carry them in
appropriate to our culture and so that
critical period it turns out
we can reopen that critical period in
adulthood by giving the mice mdma and
that is super exciting to us because it
suggests that
um you know these mag
like these miraculous seeming
um sort of therapeutic effects of mdma
that you know rick can tell you a lot
more about
um are really because
um we are reopening the critical period
and allowing
for the
pairing of that open state of the
critical period and that sort of
cognitive reappraisal or that
revisiting those memories those memory
engrams in a safe place when you combine
those two things together then you're
able to reorganize and rewrite those
memories and that's what we think is
that they're how the therapeutic effects
of mdma are working and so is this
something that i gather you think would
translate to humans but you've only done
these studies in mice is that correct
right so we think that basically what
we're doing here is what's called
reverse translation so the the studies
that have looked at mdma's effects in
curing um ptsd right the idea is is that
you're not just taking mdma and going to
a rave right you have to take mdma and
pair it with the appropriate context set
and setting psychotherapy in in the case
of the the uh
clinical trials that have been done
right and so what we're thinking that
we're doing is trying to understand how
that is working and our animal studies i
think are the first ones that i know of
that have been able to recapitulate
several key aspects of how these
therapies work right so one of them is
you know maybe not so interesting for a
general audience but has to do with the
dosing of the drugs it seems to have the
same um uh
dose response um to the drugs and mice
that we see in humans the other is about
the uh durability right so one of the
miraculous things about psychedelic
psychotherapy
is that you know some of these results
are so astonishing you give the drug and
you know immediately people feel a huge
amount of relief um there's a there
seems to be a period afterwards that um
you know people are sort of sensitive
and need to do a lot of
reconsolidation and need um extra
attention and space to be able to
process the the big revelation that they
had on the on the psychedelic
um and then and then the effects just
last for a really really long time i
mean four or five years out often right
so in some sense it's like the first
time there's the cure right and so what
we have discovered is is that mdma's
effects also have a rapid onset
um
ability to reopen the critical period
has a rapid onset and they have
extremely long durability so they last
well beyond the acute subjective effects
of the drug for in the case of mdma
lasts out to two weeks in a mouse which
might be the equivalent of two weeks in
a human or maybe longer like two months
in a human so we don't really know the
exact translation but so the durability
is the other thing and then for me the
most important thing that we're able to
recapitulate with this model of how this
drug is working is that um
the effects are context dependent so if
you give mdma to a mouse and you stick
the mouse in a room by itself
then it doesn't reopen the social
critical period but if you give the mdma
and you put the mouse in its social
context then it does reopen the social
critical period and so we think that
that dependence on the social context is
really about the fact that we're trying
to open a social critical period but
maybe wouldn't matter so much if we were
trying to open a motor critical period
right i mean i don't mean to be
facetious here but i'm just wondering so
if i took mdma
and sat down at a piano
is it possible that the critical period
for learning the motor skills of that
instrument would reopen for me are we
talking at that level of potential
reopening of critical periods yes
yes
that's i mean that is not proven at this
point
it does at this point it's not proven
but
it's definitely one of the directions
that my lab is taking because we think
that you know this insight of critical
period we think we have we're beginning
to see evidence that it generalizes
across psychedelics so it's not limited
to mdma oh and if it's not limited to
mdma
then it suggests that it you know we
originally started this research
thinking well we want to look at mdma
because mdma has these very robust acute
pro-social effects right people take
mdma and they want to do these cuddle
puddles and that's why we we picked it
and when we
you know originally were thinking about
it we thought that this would not be a
property that generalized across
psychedelics like lsd where you know
even though people talk about this
lasting sort of interconnectedness with
the world and the universe and other
people during the acute phase of the lsd
experience most people are not going
into cuddle puddles right um and so
we think that what it feels like to be
in that altered state of consciousness
is what it feels like to reopen a bunch
of critical periods and the things that
get modified are dependent on what
context you are trying to modify them
and if that's true then the type of
diseases that we might be able to cure
with psychedelics becomes rapidly i mean
massively expanded right and so we are
pursuing you know the possibility of
stroke and you know of motor learning
after stroke once the critical period is
closed but you're right it also suggests
that you know language learning learning
how to ride a bicycle learning how to
play the piano these are all potentially
things that we could reopen the critical
periods but you know it's still just
hypothesis yeah wow
now brian i just want to add that um if
you were to take mdma yeah let's say and
that you were not sitting at a piano but
you were sort of lying in a therapeutic
setting
i think that there's a good chance that
you would remember what it was like when
you were in amsterdam and you had taken
whatever it was and you were scared and
you wanted to be tied to the bed so you
wouldn't uh do unusual things that these
kind of very profound
challenging memories from the past
that they would emerge to the surface
and you would be able
to look at them from a different
perspective and you could say to process
it and where you talked about quantum
physics being you know reproducible
events but maybe psychedelics are really
just internal that there's this i would
say the the durability that google was
talking about of therapeutic outcomes
is something that we could point to that
people have revisited the past
and
reprocessed it and then their life has
changed in different ways they don't see
the world as filled with people that are
about to attack them like we see with
ptsd it's constant hyper vigilance so
i'd say that's a bit of this objective
evidence that we can have that there is
something going on in these experiences
that helps you
relate to the world in a different way
and that that can be
repeatable across large numbers of
different people in our clinical trials
and that it can be durable
wow
so so reggie do these descriptions
resonate with your say just anecdotal
experiences i mean do you do you find
that on psychedelics you sometimes or
maybe reliably feel connected to a
younger more malleable more open version
of yourself is that is that part of what
you would describe it as
um
i think so i mean the timeless self you
know this the self of self the self that
you know that's been on the journey the
whole time uh i guess there's a access
to that but i i think of that more as
like kind of an eternal thing i don't
really think of it not like as in like
there's an afterlife and although i'm
just saying like the awareness of
yourself from
onset of consciousness like i think that
there's kind of a time uh agnostic
element to a self and i think that
that's kind of what it
what it feels like i'm connecting to
that i'm connecting to my
myself self or something like that which
is very familiar it's it's more like oh
because i remember
being in the uh arboretum uh in seattle
when i used to live in seattle in the
90s and a friend of mine identified some
blue ringers that were just growing
naturally at the base of a tree in the
arboretum and he's like yeah chestnut
color fleshy top all that stuff and so
picked it and we just ate it just
straight from the ground i'd never done
that before just take a mushroom put it
in your mouth eat it had one of the most
profound experiences of my life but i
remember that the bathrooms were open in
the arboretum so i went inside and sat
down on a toilet
as a seat and i just put my head in my
hands and it's like terrible lighting in
there the worst lighting you would want
on a psychedelic trip but uh burying my
head in my hands and i just left and i
remember it felt like i went on this
huge massive like uh hyper
kind of fractal whatever just kind of
standard trip and but uh kind of like a
tunnel feeling you know just like really
cruising through some stuff and then
then arriving at this kind of quiet
place where it felt like
i met myself like some people would call
it i guess god or whatever but i call it
like self non-self you know it's and it
felt like oh i haven't seen you in a
long time there was like this kind of
feeling of like i haven't it's been so
long it's like i know i haven't seen you
in a long time it's like yeah you know
you really got to stop being so hard on
yourself you know it's like yeah i know
i know that but then that makes me think
about that too much and then i'm hard on
myself for not whatever but it was this
this this beautiful moment of of
connecting with that familiar self that
i feel is different than the self that
gains experience through being active in
life so talking about the the dualist
nondual's view
of the world
i gather and correct me if i'm wrong
that you don't view
that you have sort of non-psychedelic
experiences and psychedelic experiences
do you just sort of blend it all into
one
human mass of experience that differs
based upon whether or not you've taken a
psychedelic but it all blends together
into who you are
i 100 i i believe that you know these
states of awareness or these awarenesses
are uh they're always present i mean all
angles are present at any time so it
just depends on
what you notice and whether it's
whether it's a substance it's a chemical
substance that makes you do that or
whether it's a near-death experience or
whether it's just your fascination and a
passion with something that leads you to
that
i believe that the the intersection is
they're all the same it's all the same
intersection it just depends on
whichever angle you want to hit it's
like i have like a terrible joke about
uh there's a statue in a museum
and the statue represents racism
and uh there's a large circular bench
around it and there are all kinds of
people sat at this bench looking at the
statue but they all have a different
angle of it and some of those people are
are racists some other people are
non-racists and some people are
neither here nor there but in the end it
takes everybody to make racism work and
so whatever
object or whatever thing that someone
sees there are millions of angles that
you can go around and go that's terrible
that's actually really cool ah that's
not so bad that's terrible but it's in a
good way whatever it is and i find that
it doesn't ultimately matter i think
psychotropic psychedelics puts you in a
mind state that's much more open to that
and much more um flexible and malleable
when it comes to
people's beliefs as opposed to uh
people who study uh you know like our
two guests or study actual mechanisms uh
for you know discovering
why are we who we are and why does
anything work the way it does reggie you
know what you just said goes back to in
a way how sasha shogun invented new
drugs
is that he would invent a new drug he
would take it himself he would take it
with his wife ann but they would have a
group of 12 people
that they had worked with for decades
and they would try a new drug
and all of the different 12 people would
have slightly different experiences as
you say because they're looking at it
from slightly different angles from
their own and then once they had this
sort of consensus more or less they
would decide whether to bring it out
into the therapeutic community awesome
we took this kind of communal 12 person
group
to get a
fuller picture of what that drug
actually did ah i love that and so to
either of you or any of you think that
you know reggie you brought up racism
you know looking at statue in many
different ways
is our psychedelics a potential route to
cure some of the deep ills of the social
world
well i think so but i would say again
that
we're um the culture and the context is
more important than the experience
itself and so when we look at the
ayahuasca churches that are in brazil
that have then moved to the united
states and one of the things that also
happened in the last 10 years was the
you know the supreme court sort of
coming behind this idea of ayahuasca as
legally protected for these particular
religions but their syncretic religions
and they are
surviving only because they had to
accommodate with the catholic church
and so they are homophobic patriarchal
hierarchical so even though there's this
frequent sense of
um
you know beyond ego states of blending
that when you come out and interpret it
the cultural context has made it so that
people still are you know patriarchal
homophobic and and hierarchical so
psychedelics used in a more open
framework
can indeed i believe be an antidote to
racism to genocide to environmental
destruction but it's too simplistic to
say it's just in the psychedelic it's in
the psychedelic the context and then
where google was talking about the um
you know the critical periods being open
for sometimes weeks afterwards it's how
you integrate it how you think about it
but i think we need
help in
moving beyond
racism and all these other aspects us
and them and i think psychedelics used
wisely
with sufficient support can indeed be a
big part of the solution so with that as
a jumping-off point rick you mentioned
before some of the mdma
psychotherapy assisted studies and i
think one that you're involved with is
now phase three clinical trials and
they've had remarkable success i don't
have the data at hand but i recall that
you know a significant fraction of
patients
who received this kind of treatment were
radically helped by
this kind of combination of talk therapy
and and the psychedelics and we have
this
really a provocative and wonderful
testimonial that i'd like to play now
and just to get all your sense of
response on it so take a listen to this
my name is sarco gergearian by day i'm a
police lieutenant with the winthrop
massachusetts police department and a
psychotherapist at night
people might be shocked that a police
officer is advocating for psychedelics
but i believe we're in the middle of a
mental health crisis across the whole
country
i want to bring psychedelic assisted
psychotherapy to the police because in
policing ptsd is a big problem
there's a lot of uncertainty with this
type of work you don't know what kind of
a call is going to come in
any time an officer is waking up to go
to work their their nervous system is
activating in a really distinct kind of
way
you're not going in
calm you're tensed up you're jacked up a
little bit
you have a little bit of cortisol and
adrenaline going through your
bloodstream and that's a daily
occurrence
over time over time over the course of
an entire career it can cause problems
we're seeing the rapid escalation of
death by suicide in officers the numbers
related to depression the numbers
related to suicidality anxiety they're
staggering
your past and your training and
experience go into the way that you act
on the street
trauma tends to narrow people's
perspective
trauma taps into
fundamental
fear responses it creates
an us and them perspective
we're in a point in history right now
where
that needs to change
it's really important for us to not have
a knee on the throat of a civilian
we need to get together we need to take
walls down
and i think that medications like mdma
will be able to help with that because
it'll temper down that fear response
it'll bring in new perspective or
widened perspective to allow
for ideas around
being one
group one family
my mdma experience was federally
sanctioned a part of a research protocol
when the medicine
took effect
i had this deep overwhelming sense of
love
come across me
but what happened
right after
that sense of love
was a sense of gratitude
and it gave me the needed perspective as
to how mdma is going to help somebody
that's struggling with treatment
resistant severe ptsd
our officers will make decisions better
if they are arrested
if they are well
if their resiliency is at the highest
capacity
i care about helping with that
because i'm helping not only the
officers
but that person that intersects with
them in that moment
where that decision might have to be
made
and maybe the best possible decision
will be made
we're on a precipice of a sea change in
the way we help people
we need to destigmatize access
we need to speed up access
we need to get enough therapists trained
because when used carefully cautiously
with care and guidance under certain
protocols
i think these medicines can be very very
effective and helpful in people dealing
with their suffering
so i mean that's pretty bold right i
mean a police officer advocating the use
of what currently is a schedule one
substance uh what do you guys think
about what you just heard
i think that it's
it's tremendous um you know i
went to the international association of
chiefs of police conference years ago in
order in hopes of meeting somebody like
sarco and we did meet sarco there
and i think this idea of the us and them
you know for me it's always been that
the police have been the predators and
i've been the prey
because of the drug war
and it's been hard for me to develop
empathy for the police but i've come to
realize
you know the difficult job that they had
and that if we didn't have the drug war
there wouldn't be this kind of sense of
separation i'd say between me and my
police the police they are really
suffering a lot of alcoholism a lot of
substance abuse a lot of depression a
lot of suicide as i said in the police
what i didn't realize is that if you're
a veteran and you come back
to america you have preferential hiring
in the police so we can often get people
who are traumatized
early in their life that may have
something to do with their desire to
become a veteran to volunteer for the
military then they get traumatized in
the military then they come back and
they work in the police and you get
further traumatized so i think it's this
willingness out of desperation
from the
police community out of that sense of
desperation a willingness to look at
mdma and i think that these are not just
psychedelics for our hippies in the 60s
that these are
tools that should be mainstreamed that
can be mainstream that can have an
impact
throughout
many aspects throughout the entire
aspects of our culture and i think sarco
is
uniquely able because we're so used to
this idea of the police against drugs
for a police psychotherapist to talk
about his own personal experience
and how he sees that can help his fellow
officers it's just inspirational for me
to see that
rachel what's your take on it i mean do
you think that there's a time in the
future when whole professions police or
otherwise
may be using some of these psychedelics
as a means of doing their job better
well
i hope so i mean i i think
you know personally a lot of a lot of
the issues that we have are just
you know it's awareness it's a it's
always an awareness problem it's an
awareness issue
and with police you know i have some
friends that are
uh police persons and uh you know they
talk about how little training they have
you know they they receive a very short
amount of training um and they're just
kind of
thrust out there
you're just like
trial by fire you know go for it good
luck you know that kind of a vibe and
that's a whole awareness issue so it's
not surprising to me um to
hear about all of the
various problems that we have with
police
in our country specifically but
so i think anything like more training
uh more cycle more psychological help
that would be great so that people feel
prepared for they have a set of tools to
deal with things uh also just like on a
practical level but also on a on a
deeper psychological level so that you
you
there's you know when i was talking
about extra time that's kind of what you
want in situations like that when
situations get hectic or split second
decisions need to be made that can
really affect the trajectory of one to
multiple people's lives uh you need that
sense of extra time in in that
you have a protocol you've been trained
and you're making the best decision
possible uh so just like he said that
was my favorite thing that he that he
said that maybe a better decisions can
be made
so i think whatever helps i think a lot
of his training and i think part of that
training should be psychological help i
think that that it's very very important
for people to be trained in advance and
then also have ongoing support
throughout the the profession i think we
want the best people
the best trained people uh involved in
this service and then all the
technicalities political always blah
blah blah that's always going to be a
squabble squabble squabble but people on
the ground making decisions like that
need to be better trained
so i'm all for it and so cool do you
think that's the direction that things
will be going and how does any of that
relate to the work that you're doing in
the laboratory
yeah i mean i think i think both rick
and reggie sort of touched on this
you know again i don't think these drugs
are sort of the magic bullet i think
you know if you give a drug like mdma
and then you just sort of
reinforce your us versus them kind of
attitude
and you you bond with all the other
police officers but continue to see
the people that are in your community as
the other
then it could be very dangerous and so
the the key will be to find a way to
um
train people to have empathy for
what they
you know previously considered the other
and the context is going to be so
important for being able to
sort of
allow people to have that that cognitive
reapplause or that transformation that i
think will be necessary for these to
have the desired effect and i i just you
know i think that this is a not not to
plug too much for mechanism but i do
think that understanding how these drugs
work
will be an important part of that like i
don't think that it's a good idea to
take a police officer who does have to
sort of go out into a a strange and
difficult world and release them right
after you know what a day or two after
having a big mdma experience because i
think what our studies are telling us is
is that
p that mice and likely people also
remain in that sort of
sensitive
vulnerable child-like state for weeks
and so
just like you wouldn't put a child you
know in a rated r movie or
throw them right back into you know a
conflict type of situation i think you
know it's important to understand how
these are working and how long it takes
for a person to kind of be restored to
that
adult operational close state of the
critical period before throwing them
back in the deep end otherwise you'd
risk re-traumatizing and actually making
people worse
yeah we only have a couple minutes left
i didn't want to ask
one more question rick we began early on
in this conversation describing how
the tide is turning or it's turned was
the language that i think you use in
terms of the way
the world or at least the government
agencies are looking at psychedelics
allowing for research and
possibly taking some of these
psychedelics off of the schedule one
declaration but
is it also and i think you may reference
to this as well
does a kind of disaster await us if if
things don't unfold at the right rate
and in the right
order that society can absorb these
changes could we go back to a time
when all of these substances are simply
outlawed
well i think there's always that
possibility of a backlash
and you know who would have thought that
democracy itself would be at stake right
now i mean we grew up thinking that
democracy was so woven into the fabric
of america that that had been the
american revolution the civil war
and that now we see democracy is fragile
and it could
disappear
very soon in fact if we're not extremely
careful so i think there's always this
possibility of a backlash
and i think
you know
pacing social change according to the
way that people are necessary that's why
i'm so glad for what we're doing right
now is because what's really key is
public education
in order to
help people understand what's going on
and also to shift people away from
thinking that the power is in the drug
that's what's been fueling the drug war
it's there's good drugs there's bad
drugs and we've lost sight of the fact
that there are no such thing as good
drugs or bad drugs it's the relationship
you have with it and whether that is
productive or not
but i do think that there has been a lot
of
learning in our culture over the last 50
years since the last
backlash against psychedelics and i
think the the situation is more
desperate now than before in terms of
the
amount of anxiety depression mental
health crises the challenges that the
world is facing
so i think that there's a very good
chance that we will be able to
continue in this progress towards
mainstreaming psychedelic psychotherapy
and also then
reforming drug policy and making it
available for people like
you and your wife to go to amsterdam and
you know have that all over the place
but we have to be careful and we have to
i think the two main things that we need
to do are to not um oversell the
benefits and not to understate the risks
and that i think those were things that
happened in the 60s that the government
overstated the risks and denied that
there were any benefits and a lot of the
advocates overstated the benefits and
denied that there were significant risks
so i think we have to move forward with
a more balanced
and a lot of public education and if so
i think we'll be able to come in for a
safe landing
yeah
that would be a great way for this to
unfold cool just want to loop back to
one remark that you made early on you
said that part of your motivation early
on in going into
this kind of research is trying to
understand what consciousness is
to really you know get a handle on what
it is that allows this inner world of
experience to happen in the first place
right
so you know and that resonates with me
because the reason i do physics is i
want to understand the deep workings of
the world
because i believe that through that i
gain a certain deep communion with the
cosmos it may sound
a little bit you know lofty and
grandiose and sentiment but i really do
feel a link to the wider world when i
understand its workings do you think
that
psychedelics and the psychedelic program
will ultimately give that kind of
insight when it comes to the inner world
of conscious experience
um i do and i actually even have a
little bit of
data which is not published so i don't
want to go into too much detail about it
but you know we've touched on it a
couple times during the conversation
about sort of the mystical experience
and the fact that some people have
access to these mystical states without
actually doing psychedelics and in
mystical religious traditions a lot of
the ways that people get to those states
is by doing things like sensory
deprivation or these silent retreats or
social deprivation they go to live in
monasteries or you know in hermitages
rick talked about holotropic breath work
this is another sort of
non-psychedelic drug induced mystical
state
and yet you know it seems pretty
hopeless that we would ever be able to
understand that at a mess at a level of
mechanism by studying mice
except
that it turns out that if we um
do a social deprivation experiment in a
mouse
then we can also reopen the critical
period and we also
know from the visual
critical period literature that visual
deprivation can reopen the critical
period the visual critical period and so
it's exciting as a possibility to me
that
this overlap between the mystical
traditions that have been using these
other methods and the psychedelics
converges at the level of critical
periods and if and if we if that's true
then i think it gives us a handle to
start asking at a mechanistic level
you know what are the
neurobiological bases of you know
the big things like consciousness and
our understanding of self versus other
our understanding of life after death
those sort of bigger questions that
honestly i didn't really
think would
be
something that we would be able to work
on in my immediate lifetime but suddenly
i'm i'm feeling
rather
optimistic about about that as a as a as
an in to understand those big questions
well that would be uh astounding and
remarkable if that's uh
where this research leaves reggie one
final
i don't know if it's a question or a
request
as we wrap up here
you know we've we are we've discussed
how set and setting is vital to the
psychedelic experience so imagine that i
work up the courage to
go back and have another psychedelic
experience i'm wondering
if you would compose on the spot
a little song that would launch me on
that psychedelic journey taking me to
wherever you think it would be a good
place for me to go
oh a psychedelic song
i guess
uh god that'd be well i mean if
question i don't have my guitar here i
would say i would i would i think i got
it maybe this might help hold on i have
to close my eyes to do this because
if i'm looking at things i can't do it
okay here we go here it is
and
one
two
three four
and
six here we go we're almost ready just
systems are booting up online
reinitializing yes okay and here it oh
nope
okay here it is
okay
[Music]
hey hey that's it
hey
don't you forget what you
didn't know
cause you did it so many times before if
you are fearful then don't worry child
cause there's a bright new
sail away on a magic carpet say hello to
some friends
go to somebody's house and maybe get
them to go to the gym and if you want
some razor nets you find them in a store
don't worry baby
mescaline galore
acid galore
ketamine galore
mdma or mda
all of the things the two cps the two
ce's and all the things that make you
just go wow
psychedelics you'll love it or your
money back
absolutely fantastic so thank you so
much for that and i'll report back to
you and tell you where
that launches me at some point in the
future so thank you so much all of you
for joining us it's fascinating
conversation on psychedelics and best of
luck going forward with the performances
and the work in this vital area of
science and the mind thank you so much
[Music]
so
[Music]
you